roland is in oregon hi roland how are
you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve how can can
i help well my wife and i have been
doing the baby steps our entire marriage
about 16 months we've always been on the
same page
and recently we did a zoom call with the
financial advisor that she had before we
met
he helped her set up a roth ira and
she wanted to introduce me and he
advised us
to be fully funding her 401 and also
be saving for a home while we're paying
off student debt and so
now she wants to throw your plan out the
window and i want to keep going like a
gazelle to pay that debt and
i don't know how to get her back back on
the plan
i don't either yeah
well she thinks now that that you your
your steps are kind of a broad stroke
for people who are making poor decisions
and uh doesn't really fit [ __ ]
they're designed for people like her let
me take a stab at this how much how much
debt do you have right now
134. 134 000 made up of what
student debt all student loans yeah any
of that
any of that hers no sir it's all yours
how much do you make how much do you
make
i i'm making nine right now i'm i'm a
full-time seminary student
she makes 340. she makes 340 000
a year yes sir and you're she's a doctor
yeah she is a a surgeon yes
okay that's going to hurt my plan
because here's the stab i was going to
take and that is that she's got to see
that
while this guy has made this advice to
her that you still got this
debt and you're and you're it's going to
take so much longer to pay it off doing
it
his way in her way and you're going to
actually make progress faster part of
the problem dave i think is we've got a
a
she's the full-time income she's the
only income and she's making big money
and she doesn't feel it doesn't hurt her
enough
the debt doesn't hurt rowan i don't know
how to help you let me tell you what
you're experiencing
yeah 30 years of me coaching people in
finance
the worst people the worst
category of people handling money are
medical doctors
as a category they suck at handling
money
worse than pro athletes worse than
anybody
and the reason is is that they're very
very smart
intellectually and they make the mistake
of thinking that that translates to
finance
they don't know beans about finance but
they have an
intellectual arrogance and they go make
stupid but decisions
and they firmly believe with all of
their intellectual arrogance
that they're making the right decisions
and it's the worst category now not all
medical doctors are that way but
it's stereotypical i mean i'm in
nashville with country music artists
some of them do some stupid butt stuff
some of them are brilliant with money
uh i mean i meet everybody from actors
to pro
athletes to whatever over 30 years
the worst category are medical doctors
they are perpetually in debt
and they're perpetually underperforming
in their wealth building
because of their intellectual arrogance
and that's what you're running into and
i don't know how to fix that
because now she and her little financial
advisor
who between the two of them don't know
beans uh about money
have made a decision so i really i i
don't know how to help you sir how long
before you get out of seminary and start
working it doesn't matter
i mean well i'm just 340 000 they could
pay it all off in one year
but i mean unless he convinced but
instead the financial advisor kept her
is keeping student loans around like
they're a freaking pet
i got she got a hundred and forty
thousand dollars of student loan debt
she makes 340 000 if you can't pay that
off in a year you're a wimp
that's ridiculous it's ridiculous that
this advisor
takes this poor a stance and leaves this
couple
in debt this far you should be sued for
malpractice
as a financial advisor for doing that
that's just asinine
just asinine but they're gonna do it
so i honestly don't know how to help you
that's what you're coming up against
though
and um truthfully some humility on her
part
is in order and saying you know what i
really don't know
anything about this area i just listened
to this one guy
and you know he disagrees with the other
guy
and so maybe now we can have a
discussion but no no no
don't doubt dave ramsey's a knuckle
dragger and his his ideas are primitive
and they're broad strokes how about the
broad stroke your idiot financial
planner gave
you there's a broad stroke for you
so i mean just just god aggravating his
crud
so i i honestly don't know how to help
you i really don't know how to convince
someone
in that situation what to do i think
you're going to experience
pain before you do and i think you're
going to
experience that she makes a lot of money
and you're not going to get the
best use of it as long as you're
following this idiot that she had on the
phone well the one thing we can do is he
can if she's not going to get on
board then once he starts working he's
going to take all of his salary and yeah
but
now we're telling people to split their
money apart and that's going to split
couples apart that's not healthy for
their relationship
well no well i'm not one hold on because
i don't want to confuse the audience i'm
not suggesting that they split their
money
i'm saying well they have a split plan
her plan and his plan
well but he's not going to not pay the
debt off yeah well he's got to pay it
off he is if he goes along with her
yeah so i mean you're not going to pay
it off for 30 years if he goes along
with her yeah that's true i think he's
got to sit down and show where if we pay
this off look how much more we can
invest how much quicker that's the only
shot he's got it's
just a little bit she married a seminary
student so maybe we ought to read the
bible
there is borrower is slave to the lender
that's true about that let's try that
one yeah
i just don't the only thing is dave i
just don't think you were clear enough
with him and i don't think he showed
enough emotion
i feel like you mailed that i feel like
you mailed that call in ah
no i get it it's frustrating it's a
tough situation because this is a
marriage well it is
and you know he's getting bullied
well okay so i'm going to bring this up
and i don't and if you send a hate mail
i'm not going to read it so don't send
it
uh well go ahead and send it we use it
for kindling yeah that's true we do we
use it for the fire pit out back
um how much this has nothing to do with
her being a woman him being a man but
how much of this is the fact that it's
his
debt student loan debt and she's the
sole bread winner i think that's a
big factor in this isn't it it can be in
the fact that she doesn't think he's got
a vote
yeah that's what i'm getting now she's
going this is something should have been
handled before you get married i agree
that you know this is a messy
psychological deal given her
100 of their marriage she's going to out
earn him
yes unless he has some kind of
ridiculous career in ministry that that
most people don't have right i mean a
pastor's income is not going to keep up
with a medical doctor's income
and 340 000 a year in 99
of the cases so this is going to be an
issue for 50 years
oh big time if that's if this is really
marital counseling
yeah just like any other problem with it
be parenting hey
she wants to discipline the kids this
way i think it's this way this is a big
issue this is marital counseling is what
this is this is the shot to get somebody
objective in there in the middle
let both of them hear each other out and
they've got they've got to fight
on this as a married issue this is just
like any other major issue in your
marriage in fact maybe bigger let me
explain to you what i'm talking about
because
some medical doctors are all mad at me
now because i didn't call all of you i
said the category
okay it's a stereotype right which means
that some people aren't
right but here's the thing
the people that have the most trouble
with money
are oftentimes the most
that have the best and the highest
intellect
because they over think it they think
it's a math problem
and personal finance is only 80 behavior
20 head knowledge it is a math problem
but it is not the problem the problem is
your relationships
the problem is understanding the flow
of your income and you know where it's
going to go
understand the spiritual principles that
are underlying all of this
and uh you know sometimes i run into an
accountant
or an engineer or i don't know
name somebody an attorney someone else
who you know
and there can be people in other catego
other career fields that have high
intellect but i'm people
people are highly intelligent and highly
analytical
and both also are the ones that struggle
the most to win
with money well remember this the most
of the world used to think the world was
flat dave
and these people are running in a world
where it says you just go you get the
debt and you're eventually going to out
earn it it's not a problem
so if everybody says it then you just
believe it you should just do everything
at the same time
you need to get out of debt that's right
the world is flat
now we've confused everyone now i'm just
lost yeah
i am truly a knuckle driver